so that brings us to Suzy Thompson she
is an associate professor and plant
breeder at NDSU she develops new potato
cultivars for growers the industry and
also consumers she grew up on a seed
farm here in the Red River Valley and
she loves anything out in the field and
according to Suzy the best part of her
job is working with potato growers
gardeners and students so with that
thanks for being with us today Suzy
Thank You Julie for that nice
introduction and happy first day of
spring to everyone I hope that everybody
is in the gardening mood since it's
finally bright sunny and fairly warm out
today I just came from the greenhouse
where I was crossing so I had my North
Dakota Caribbean escape for the day and
I can't help but be excited for the
upcoming planting season whether it's in
the field or out in our own yards or
even pots on our sidewalks I wanted to
remind everybody that you can type in
questions and then as Julie indicated
when I'm finished with my presentation
then I will go ahead and try to answer
those questions that you've submitted
the title of my presentation today is
one potato two potato three potato four
best management practices to produce
more and of course I was reminded or or
came up with this title because of an
old nursery rhyme that many of us
probably remember I can't the part I
can't remember is if we used to sing it
while we jump rope tour or or when it
was that we used it but but anyway
potatoes are near and dear to my heart
so I I chose that as a way to talk about
production and and how we might optimize
production in our gardens please advance
the slide so potato as a kind of a
background potato is a member of the
nightshade family or the Solanaceae in
that family are about 2,000 species only
160 of them are tuber bearing there are
20 called
the rated species that we would consider
to be potato or wild potato relatives
and of course the botanical name for the
common potato that we raise or what some
people might refer to as the white
potato or Irish potato is solanum
tuberosum please advance the slide and a
little bit more in relationship to the
botany but so being a member of the
Solanaceae potato is a relative of
tomato eggplant pepper tobacco petunias
and of course one of our favorite not
really favorite weeds the nightshades we
grow potato tubers for their potatoes
for their underground tubers and kind of
to help put everybody into perspective
potato tubers are really modified stems
so things that can go on in potato
foliage can go on in potato tubers too
and I'll try to come back to this or I
definitely will come back to it when we
talk about potato storage but also when
we talk a little bit about some
physiological disorders that might
impact potato potato would be what we
would consider to be an herbaceous die
cut so dicot means that it would have
two cotyledons it's not a grass and
herbaceous of course means that it's
succulent and potatoes are annuals
potato has its origin in the south
american andean region and it stretches
all the way from that backbone of the
Andes all the way up through Central
America Mexico into the Four Corners
region of the US so the people from the
gene Bank in Sturgeon Bay Wisconsin they
actually do collection expeditions in
the Four Corners region of Arizona
Colorado Utah and and look for some wild
species that are growing in the wild and
and important and native to that
particular particular region
in terms of production the potato
industry is more than a four billion
dollar industry North Dakota as you can
see on this table ranks third in terms
of the acreage harvested and but not
always in turn and usually in terms of
production sometimes we are eclipsed and
in this case you'll see that Wisconsin
in 2017 surpassed North Dakota in terms
of their total production as well as the
value then but we often times will
flip-flop between our two states and
they have the potential for a higher
yield in Wisconsin they have a little
bit longer of a growing season and of
course in North Dakota our production is
based on both non irrigated as well as
irrigated production in terms of
certified seed potato production North
Dakota ranked second only after Idaho
and just for those of you that might be
curious where Minnesota would rank
Minnesota in terms of production usually
ranks about sixth there are many
cultivars more than 200 cultivars a
potato that are available to producers
in of the US or in North America these
are the on the list are the predominant
cultivars in order of their production
but many of these are not necessarily
the right choice for gardeners you will
recognize probably dark-red Norland and
also russet nor Koda of course Norland
was released from NDSU in 1957 and
russet nor Koda in the early or excuse
me late 1980s and so those cultivars you
can oftentimes find at your local
gardening center or the grocery store
that might be carrying some seed
potatoes etc but these are the
predominant varieties in terms of
commercial production in the US for
market classes this might be a area
where some of you will have a keen
interest there are basically four
classes the first would be our round
white
and in our growing area the round whites
that we grow are high in dry matter
content so they kind of have a mealy dry
texture and of course they're used to
make potato chips out on the East Coast
though there is a market for round
whites that would have a lower dry
matter so they would use them more
similarly to how we use red potatoes
here the texture would be more creamy or
more waxy and so they would be using
those for boiling and then a home fries
or making potato salad or things like
that the important features for making
potato chips of course would be that
high dry matter content as when we are
doing the processing the water content
of the potato is replaced by oil in that
frying process and then the amount of
sugar in the tuber is usually less when
we have high dry matter potatoes in
favor of starch and that results in a
lighter chip or french fry color so the
those are some features that would be
important for for that market class ii
market class and hopefully everybody can
find the kind of brown color tubers and
on the left hand side of the photos
there is the long russet and whites and
some of these are used for processing
and many of them are also used for table
stock or for fresh use so some important
characteristics for these are again if
they're going to be used for french fry
processing that they have that high
specific gravity or that high dry matter
so a potato variety like russet Burbank
is is number one for making french fries
all across the globe and and of course
they need that elongates shape with the
russets for the table stock industry
something like restin are kota these
will tend to have a lower specific
gravity so again that more waxy or
creamy texture they tend to be higher in
sugars and and and so they don't make
good french fries they would fry too
dark they would be caramel e and
um probably even smell a little bit
burnt when when we would cook them not
not necessarily right after you harvest
them but certainly after you would store
them particularly at temperatures that
we store table stock potatoes at on the
bottom are some bread selections from a
field day that NDSU was a part of and
these are showing reds for the table
stock industry or or four fresh use and
these of course are very popular in our
area the Red River Valley is quite
famous for its red potato production
they tend to again have that creamy or
waxy texture they make excellent
additions the soup to do they make great
mashed potatoes and of course these are
really the potatoes that we're looking
for when we are going to be making the
traditional potato salad and then lastly
on the middle right is a picture of what
I would consider to be our heirlooms or
our specialties probably everyone is
pretty familiar with Yukon Gold and of
course that has a soft yellow flesh
interior of the tuber and some people
also might maybe will have heard of a
variety called all blue it's an old
variety from Europe that came across
with our ancestors there's also all red
and now some of the breeding programs
around the US are starting to release
others some with additional cultivars
that have red blush or blue flesh I add
around that blue for example comes out
of Cornell so the heirlooms and
specialties with the exception of Yukon
Gold are probably not found routinely in
most grocery stores at least in our area
however they tend to be more frequently
found at farmers markets during the
summer or during the fall for in terms
of utilization about 88% of the potato
production in the u.s. is used for human
consumption about 61% is used for of
that is used for processing and 26% of
that is used
the production is used for the fresh
market potatoes 7% of our production is
used for seed potatoes six percent would
be shrink or those losses that a potato
grower might suffer in storage and then
less than 1% is now used for livestock
feed when we would go across the pond to
Europe they feed a significantly higher
portion of their livestock with potatoes
than we do here in the US in terms of
nutritional attributes I think that
potato oftentimes gets a bad rap in the
media but really potatoes should be
considered a little powerhouse our
average potato that we would be baking
or maybe we have multiple potatoes
little B sized tubers small ones
totaling about five ounces it would
equal a serving and that single serving
only has 100 calories potatoes have no
fat they have no cholesterol and no
sodium however potatoes actually have
higher amounts of potassium than a
banana and of course in the media and
with some nutrition folks banana has
kind of been the poster child for high
potassium foods potato does have high
total carbohydrates and sometimes in the
literature we hear that potato is bad
because it has a high glycemic index I
think that more and more research is
showing that it really depends upon what
foods you're consuming with the potatoes
yes if you're just eating chip after
chip out of a bag that probably is going
to impact your blood sugar quite rapidly
but if you're having mashed potatoes
with a bit of salmon or some other type
of lean meat elk or or beef that is
going to impact how quickly the
carbohydrates are broken down and
shuttled into your bloodstream and
potato is high in dietary fiber it
provides about three grams and of course
obviously if we eat the potato skins or
include them if we're making mashed
potatoes or for eating our baked potato
that would help us a reach that that
fiber level and four potatoes are
actually pretty high in protein when
compared with other vegetables or fruits
and another area where potato really
shines even the white fleshed cultivars
but one serving of potato provides about
45 percent of the u.s. RDA for vitamin C
that's even higher than an orange or a
serving of oranges so I hope that
everyone will reconsider the the
nutritional attributes that potato can
provide and how it can be a part of a
healthy lifestyle since we're talking
about potatoes I thought it would be a
good idea to maybe share just a little
bit of background about our potato
breeding program at NDSU it was begun in
1930 so we have more than a 85-year
history now during that time 26
cultivars have been released or
varieties I used the two terms
interchangeably but usually hear talk
about cultivars the major goal or
objective of our breeding program is to
release exceptional multi-purpose
cultivars that meet the needs of potato
producers and the industry in North
Dakota Minnesota the Northern Plains and
beyond and for some of you guys as I had
mentioned the Norland and russet nor
Kota but the picture I have there on the
bottom is of the famous potato breeder
dr. Bob Johansen and obviously nowadays
we grow red Norland and dark red Norland
but he released Norland in 1957 and to
think that we're still growing line
selections from that is is pretty
impressive and pretty exciting and this
is just a listing of the cultivar
releases coming from NDSU all the way
from Nordic nor Clayman Norland that
were released in
19:57 I don't know I have read norland
on that list but seem to have a spare
one there and and then all the way
through Dakota Ruby which was released
in 2014 we have a lot of different Minds
coming along in our pipeline here at
NDSU so I'm hoping that in the next few
months we'll be releasing a new chip
variety and/or a new very early russet
variety that would be great for people's
gardens in a short growing season in
terms of climate and soil potato is a
cool season crop and the optimum
temperatures that potatoes like to
thrive under would be in that
temperature range of 55 to 70 degrees
Fahrenheit
even up to 75 potatoes do not really
like hot temperatures at all and at
temperatures above 87 to 90 degrees
Fahrenheit photosynthesis will decrease
or actually stop and of course that
photosynthetic production during the
daytime is turned into starches and
shuttle down and deposited it as the
intimate our tubers at night time during
the our summer months after we've had
tuber ization so production of the
photosynthate is very important potatoes
have a high water requirement and this
is predominantly due to them having a
shallow root system so the roots of
potato are primarily in the 18 top 18
inches of our soil and this is a much
more shallow root system than our
agronomic crops like wheat or barley
alfalfa goes down about 6 feet deep is
more similar to many of our vegetable
crops and so most of us are familiar
that we need to be able to provide a
consistent and uniform irrigation or
have timely rainfall in order to get
adequate production potatoes prefer
well-drained and slightly acid soils
but they are really widely adapted and
potatoes will grow from sea level all
the way to high mountains they obviously
like the sandy or sandy loam type of
soils but they also do very well in
things like muck soils or in peat based
soils like we have near gone Vic or
clear broken Nam in Minnesota in terms
of pH they will grow on a wide variety
of PHS and out east there are soils that
they grow potatoes on that would have a
pH in that four point five to five range
and I have been working in breeding
programs and cultivar development
programs all around the Intermountain
West and many producers are growing
potatoes on soils where the pH is seven
point eight or eight the reason why we
talk about soil pH is that sometimes we
say or and and we see it there happens
to be more common scab and I'll show you
some pictures of what color a picture of
what common scab is on an upcoming slide
but I think that it really depends upon
what bio types of the streptomyces you
might have in your soil and then what
beneficial flora and fauna you might
have in your soil that would help
protect the developing tubers and and
that pH isn't the the complete answer
shall we say my next bullet I have day
length written down and day length is
important because of the wild species
particularly many of our wild potato
species will not trooper eyes under long
day conditions but as all of you are
familiar with we have very long days
during our summer times here when we're
producing potatoes so our our potatoes
are usually setting tubers right around
that June 21 the longest day of the year
the first day of summer and and then
rapidly bulking after that but when I
try to use
while potato species that came from
places like Peru or Ecuador or or even
Central America or Mexico a lot of them
will not start to rise until the day's
get to be quite short like we have in
September and so it's hard for me to
maybe maintain tubers of those those
particular clones and I would be using
those as a way to inter grass late
blight resistance for example or maybe
resistance to Colorado potato beetles or
things like that and and I'm doing my
crossing in the greenhouse but I like to
be able to to grow the potatoes out in
the field and so lots of times those
will be just little itty-bitty tiny
things when we go to harvest them when
whereas our solanum tuberosum that had
its origins in the area of southern
chile near of chile island they tuber
eyes under long day conditions so not
something that's so important maybe for
you gardeners to think about but it is
important for for the potato industry to
be aware of so let's talk a little bit
more about our prepping our potatoes for
production so we'll talk about
propagation there are two types of
propagation that we do or can use for
potato production the primary one of
course is asexual reproduction and
that's where we use either a small whole
tuber or we use a piece of a tuber it's
also referred to as clonal propagation
and when we are doing a potato seed
certification we will utilize plantlets
that we grow in test tubes that would be
free from diseases this would be the
start of the seed certification system
but each one of those plant lights or
each one of those pieces of potato would
be a clone of the the same variety and
so it's also referred to as clonal
propagation in terms of our seed
potatoes in Europe they tend to plant
the small potatoes haul in
u.s. we generally will our seed will be
bigger so we will be cutting it either
in half so that we wind up with two
pieces that are about two to three and a
half ounces or or we might be cutting 8
ounce tuber into 4 pieces that would
make that that optimum range of a two to
three and a half ounce seed piece the
important feature of course is that each
seed piece needs to have an eye because
that's where the new stem will develop
from and we breeders however and I have
a couple of pictures on the bottom of
this slide we create and use what is
called true potato seed and so if any of
you have seen what some people will call
those little Tomatoes on top of the
potato plant those are our potato
berries or potato fruits they can
contain up to 250 individual seeds
because of the highly heterozygous
nature meaning we have a lot of genes
and there's a lot of diversity in those
genes each one of those brother and
sister seeds in one of those fruits will
be genetically different from or can be
genetically different from all of the
other brothers and sisters so when I
make a cross and plant out the seed in
the greenhouse oh and then take the
tubers that I grow in the greenhouse
from those the and plant them in the
field it will kind of look like a
patchwork quilt I can have different
flower colors it can have different
maturities we can have different skin
colors we can have different flesh
colors just a myriad of of traits it's
really fun and and so if anyone's
interested in you know either harvesting
the berries and extracting the seed or
doing a little crossing on your own I'm
cross pollinating then and growing them
out that can be a real fun project with
your kids or or just as an adult to see
the diversity that you can attain in the
wild the primary pollinator is the
bumblebee but that's not important for
potato production in the garden we're
using clonal propagation so we are
trying to produce all potatoes that look
alike and of you know probably one
variety I guess a couple of other points
that I should make in terms of prepping
for planting and propagating we can cut
our tubers it's a good idea to use a
sharp knife we don't want to use a
serrated knife the potato seed will heal
better if it's a nice clean cut or sharp
cut we will need about 15 pounds of seed
potatoes to plant a 100 foot row and
we'll talk a little bit more about
spacing in a subsequent slide when we
are searching for seed potatoes
obviously garden catalogues are a
typical source or a lot of our local
grocery stores will carry seed potatoes
in their produce section you should not
choose the potatoes from their produce
display however because more than likely
those potatoes have been treated with a
sprout inhibitor to prevent them from
sprouting and because of that if you
tried to cut them and plant them in your
garden you might not get any any of the
eyes to to sprout and grow a new plant
so we recommend that you purchase your
seed potatoes either from a reputable
seed grower or from a reputable garden
catalog or or from one of your local
garden centers or or perhaps grocery
stores I'm gonna diverge from my slides
here just for one second so please you
can go ahead and leave it on this one I
didn't talk much about cultivars when I
showed the slide about what cultivars
were are being grown by the commercial
potato farmers but the typical cultivars
that you'd probably find in the in your
seed catalogs are some of the older
varieties you might find cannabis
her Irish cobbler obviously red Norland
red Pontiac sometimes red lesotho 's
many people like to grow a few russet so
I think a typical one that you would
find would be gold rush I do not
recommend trying to grow russet Burbank
in your gardens recipe Bank is quite
temperamental and it doesn't do
particularly well in our heavy soils
like we have in the Fargo Moorhead area
and it also is very temperamental when
it comes to water it has to have their
uniform water in order to produce nice
smooth attractive looking tubers so I
don't recommend that you purchase rest
the Burbank or or look for that in our
area you might find some russet nor
quotas and some Vikings at your local
seed retailers and of course Yukon Gold
Yukon Gold is a great variety to grow in
your garden it's quite upright it
doesn't produce a lot of tubers per
plant though so you may want to plant
them a little bit closer and plant a few
more heals the tubers when they get big
for Yukon Gold oftentimes will have
hollow heart if the moisture hasn't been
quite uniform or if you let them get to
be too large and but they are a good you
know quite early maturing potato and
they are really have so many uses
they're kind of my go-to in terms of
multi-use when I'm cooking here at NDSU
we've released some great varieties that
are probably a little bit harder to
track down but if you know a seed potato
grower and you want to get something
into or talk to your local grocery store
produce manager or your garden center
manager and they can talk to the
certified seed potato growers but it
takes about three years to get geared up
to produce potato support a new market
so if somebody wanted to grow our
beautiful to quote a ruby for example it
produces a high set of
beautiful bright red skin round like
apples potatoes very high yielding but
in order to you know you probably aren't
going to find it in the marketplace and
so you might have to ask and then it
might take them a year or two to be able
to get them in but I would like to hope
that some people would be adventurous
and and try to maybe explore some
different potato varieties than the old
standards okay we can advance to
planting so when we are going to be
planting in our gardens we're not going
to be using a fancy machine like we have
here for planting our research plots but
I thought that it was kind of a good
picture because it shows the hills that
oftentimes we will use and as gardeners
you might want to be forming as well and
you have the opportunity to form those
hills before you plant and then plant
into them or you can plant into flat
ground and then create a hill as part of
your cultivation weed control whatever
you want to call it in the garden and
I'll talk more about healing I believe
in the next slide so for spacing in our
Gardens most of us will plant our
potatoes and rows that range from 30 to
36 inches wide or the distance from the
top of the hill or the the row from the
distance between the two rows would be
30 to 36 inches some potato growers will
also use 38 inch rows but it just
depends upon what equipment they own so
so you are welcome to do what you might
where what might work best for you
within the row most of us will plant 10
to 12 inches apart or you know somewhere
around the foot between plants are
between seed pieces if we want to
produce a high volume of very small
tubers then we might want to put our
seed pieces closer together within the
row so maybe
plant them at eight inches if that is
the desired supersize profile that we
would be after and then I have the word
beds on my little bullet points here
some people are starting to grow
potatoes in what would I would call a
raised bed it would be like a hill
except that it would be three feet wide
so you would you would build it up and
then it would be three feet wide and
some people will plant basically three
rows of potatoes but they will be offset
so they're more in a diamond shape and
um and again you can use whatever seed
or within row spacing that you want
depending upon what you're going to be
doing with the potatoes or what size of
potatoes you want and when we plant we
usually plant our potatoes so that
they're about four inches deep so if
we've already ready formed our Hill then
we will poke them down to about four
inches below if we are going to plant
our potatoes and then form the hill we
might just want to poke them in a couple
of inches and then build up that hill as
I mentioned when we're doing our Reed
control in terms of fertilization most
of us would base our fertility
management on a soil test and even we
gardeners should probably be testing our
soil every few years you know we're
rotating our different vegetable crops
around we are maybe adding some compost
that we're making in a barrel on our
patio sometimes there is you know
backyard flooding so we are getting a
mixture of soil from new construction
you know in our neighborhood or or
varying things so doing a soil test is a
good idea and here at North Dakota State
University we do have a soil testing lab
and so you can
um get a little bag from them or or just
pull a few cores from your soil and put
them in a paper bag and Mail em and
bring them in and they can run a little
soil test report I would recommend going
down to 12 inches in your garden and
like I said do it every five years or
three to five years or three to eight
years just so they kind of have an idea
when it comes to actual fertilizers we
can use commercial fertilizers like we
would get at any of the big box stores
or at our gardening centers but we can
also use manure or other types of
organic sorts of fertilizers and and it
doesn't really matter what we are
shooting for is we want to supply our
potato plants with the proper amount of
fertilizer so that we can attain a high
yield with our commercial growers we
have a little chart and we say that you
know depending upon your soil test and
your yield goal this is what you should
be providing in terms of n P and K
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium for we
gardeners I guess I use more of a rule
of thumb that we need to apply about 1/3
of a pound of nitrogen for every 100
square feet of potato production we have
going on some of us might have those
beds or some of us might have rows and
so I'll let you kind of do your own math
but but that would be kind of a general
rule of thumb for when we don't
necessarily have a recent soil test when
we are placing our fertilizer whether it
be commercial fertilizer or manure we
can work it into the soil pre plant or
if we want to we can when we're using
commercial fertilizers like granular
fertilizers we can place it two inches
to the side and two inches below our
seed piece the reason why we don't want
to put it right with our seed piece is
that we
can the the salts and commercial
fertilizers can cause burning to the
developing roots and Duvall developing
shoots so that's a reason why we might
avoid putting at least any type of
volume of the commercial fertilizer in
close proximity to our seed pieces a
typical fertilizer that I recommend for
potato production we use it on the farm
I use it in my research plots and it's a
good one that home gardeners can usually
access would be something like fifteen
thirty fifteen and just to refresh
everybody's memory that first 15 stands
for in the thirty stands for or I said
in and didn't say nitrogen the thirty
stands for P for phosphorous and the
fifth the last fifteen stands for K for
potassium potatoes are a high user of
phosphorous and especially with some of
the pH is that our soil pH is that we
have in this area our phosphorous might
not be as readily available as some
areas where they have a lower pH of soil
so it's important that we select a a
fertilizer that has a high phosphorous
content or that we add supplemental
phosphorous because it's very important
for tuber production and for high
quality tubers let me see then comment
about manure we should um use well aged
manure typically I would recommend that
you apply manure to your garden in the
fall before you're going to be planting
whatever vegetables but especially
potatoes and the part of the reason for
this is that if the manure is not you
know somewhat composted already it has
been implicated and causing common scab
on potatoes but it also is more likely
to be harboring things like
weed seeds or even some insect pests and
things like that
so we like to say to incorporate
well-aged manure and to do that in the
fall prior to our growing season now we
can advance asides to the culture okay
so I talked a little bit about healing
and hopefully this picture you can see
the hills and how the potatoes are
coming up in the middle of those hills
healing is important for potato
production for two reasons number one is
it helps with water management so if we
get a heavy rain or if we're using an
overhead sprinkler in our garden the
water will stay in the fertile part
hopefully and our potato plants will not
have to wet the feet hopefully that's
one reason for the healing and of course
the other reason for the healing is to
help prevent greening of our developing
tubers even sometimes as we're
approaching fall and we maybe have had
some dry soils we maybe have a really
great potato crop coming up as our vines
start to senesce or our plants start to
die there might be some cracks in our
soil and sometimes we'll find that our
tubers have little green lines or green
splotches on them because they have been
exposed to the light remember I said
that the tuber was a modified stem so
anything that happens to the foliage can
happen to the tubers and greening is one
of those things the tuber will develop
chlorophyll just like our stems so
irrigation a reminder the potato plant
is shallow rooted that are primarily in
the top 18 inches when we have water
stress we might see our potato plants
wilting we might see a Bluegreen gray
color to our foliage and when we go to
harvest our potatoes we might start to
see some misshapen tubers they might be
pointy on one end they might be shaped
like a dumbbell there might be some
external defects things like growth
cracks or what I call knobs that are
second growth
when we go to cook them and cut into
them we might see some internal problems
things I call a heart so potatoes don't
like water stress but they also don't
like being over watered and that's the
reason why I have our bullet late season
watering as we start to see our potato
plants start to senesce or die that
you'll see a yellow chlorosis and the
plants probably will have kind of
started to crouch down or lay down in
the rows they're not being hugely
photosynthetically active probably we
don't want to overwater at this point
because we can create problems where our
tubers are struggling to breathe you
might see some little white freckles on
the potatoes when you would dig them out
of wet soil those are the breathing
pores and when the potatoes are
struggling to breathe in the soil they
will the those breathing pores will kind
of expand and they almost look fuzzy
those white freckles but because those
breathing pores are wide open we can
have some pathogens enter and then this
can limit the shelf life or the storage
life of our potatoes in our root cellar
or in our potato storages so we need to
be cognizant of late season watering I
don't really have a bullet point in here
indicating how much a water we should be
using or how much irrigation we should
be doing but typically we want to keep
the top 12 inches of soil damp and we
would be thinking about supplying about
one inch of water per week a potato crop
will use between eighteen and thirty six
inches of water depending upon our soil
type for a whole growing season you know
for a hundred to 120 day growing season
so so I you know certain soils are going
to like hot dry sands are going to
require heavier watering
then if we're growing potatoes on our
loans or certainly on our clay soils
like we have here in the Red River
Valley now on the next couple of slides
we're going to talk about pest control
and we'll start out talking about weed
control first my first comment would be
if you want to change slides would be
that we do not use a herbicide in the
garden now for growing potatoes for
farmers market scenario you're probably
going to have larger areas but when
we're gardening we tend to have a lot of
different species and very close
proximity to one another so I don't
really recommend using herbicides in our
home gardens instead that should be what
I tell my mom is it's therapy after work
you know at the end of the day it's a
nice fun way to go out and you know do a
little puttering around after supper
weeding and tending to your garden it's
a very peaceful enjoyable time of the
day to listen to the birds talk to your
backyard neighbors just you know just a
better way to handle weeds but there are
some weeds that particularly seem to be
problematic and potatoes some of them
like the nightshade like the picture
that I'm showing here they're related to
potatoes and so the two seem to come
hand in hand but we might see things
like foxtails or wild oats in our farm
fields a lot of times you'll see
volunteers cereal grains so we might
wind up with oats or wheat or barley
depending what the previous crop here
was oftentimes in our gardens we'll see
things like wild mustard I definitely
find a lot of pig weeds and lambs
quarters in my garden buckwheat is
becoming a problem in some areas
certainly Canada thistle can be
problematic if we have it in our our
yards or in a row ditch that it can
easily move and the more tillage we do
the more calm canada thistle spreads and
then of course in my garden i oftentimes
will find kosher
and it depends on where you're growing
your gardens are where you might be
growing potatoes for the for a farmers
market or or a field but um the
complexion of weed species might change
depending where you are on the globe for
insect pests the major insect pest
potato is Colorado potato beetle and
oddly I worked in Colorado for six years
in the San Luis Valley we didn't have
Colorado potato beetles but the original
naming of the beetles came because they
identified these beetles that once they
started producing potatoes in Colorado
came off with a buffalo purr which again
is related related species to potato and
and so that was in the northeastern
corner kind of near that Greeley area so
so that's how Colorado potato beetle got
its name but it doesn't mean that
beetles grow everywhere in Colorado so
the top three photos that I have the top
photo shows you the the adult and they
do some defoliation the middle photo
shows you a potato plant that was the
foliated by beetles and then if you look
very very closely on that that very
bottom of the top three but actually
turns out to be the middle photo on the
slide you'll see some little larvae that
sort of look like fat little slugs and
some people refer to these as pigs
because they're kind of pink and they
start out tiny in red the eggs would be
found on the undersides of the leaves
and they usually are a yellowy orange
color and then the closer they get to
hatching they they kind of start to
become this orange yellow or orange
--red color
but these little larvae then when they
hatch they start eating and so the the
size of these ones would have quite
ferocious appetites and they can consume
a lot of potato foliage in just a day or
two again in your garden I'm not sure if
you really need to be using an insect
side for control a lot of people will
handpick them or you can shake them into
a little coffee can of something like
turpentine or you can just collect them
into a container and put them into your
trash you know in if you are
uncomfortable with killing them but we I
think in our home gardens controlling
them is using insecticides is not as
important as controlling them using
another method like hand picking the
bottom right hand picture it is a
picture of green peach aphids and they
are literally covering the potato Foley
agent in that particular photo if it's
you'll sometimes find in your garden
they vector viruses or they can transmit
potato viruses in your garden it's
probably not a big deal but it's a huge
issue for our certified seed potato
growers so they like to control aphids
many of them as a sustainable practice
will release ladybird beetles because
they're a natural predator of aphids
that's something that you can purchase I
know in some of the garden catalogs you
can purchase a little tub of of ladybird
beetles and let them go free in your
garden but for the most part growers
have commercial growers have a hard time
using any kind of insecticide because
the aphids move and and they fly and so
they struggle with that so they have to
you know do other things which is number
one try not to have potatoes with
viruses in close proximity to your seed
fields if you do have a feds in your
crop you might see some honeydew or you
might see some crinkling of leaves like
our end
kind of some rolling like we see in this
photo that could be a symptom of their
their activity leafhoppers can be a
problem in our area these little insects
are quite tiny they do hop they sort of
look like a teeny teeny teeny tiny
grasshopper if you look at them closely
they have wings they blow up on the
winds from southern states and so
sometimes if they've had a lot of them
in southern states on other crops and
they blow up will have few leaf hoppers
around early in the summer generally not
something that we need to control
usually the predator insects get them
flea beetles are another one that
occasionally will see it we'll get that
child holing effect I ate my go to plant
if I am wondering if I have flea beetles
I look at my radish plants because flea
beetles seem to like radishes better
than everything so that's the the story
on insects the bottom picture is of wire
worms and particularly if we're taking
our or putting a garden in where we have
just taken it out of sod or out of
alfalfa we might see wire worms very
rarely do we have grubs potato diseases
in your garden hopefully you're not
going to see too many the upper
left-hand picture is a picture of common
scab again it's caused by fungus in the
soil called streptomyces you may or may
not have it it's a good reason to rotate
spots in your garden and we can
certainly peel it away it's not harmful
it just doesn't look appetizing early
blight is the picture in the middle and
if you have a chance to come back and
review this you'll see that those little
lesions look like a bull's-eye the funny
thing about early blight is early blight
tends to come in late when our potatoes
maybe have some kind of stress and late
blight tends to come in earlier in the
girl
season late blade is in the lower
left-hand bottom picture and if we tip
those leaves over we might see some
mycelial growth around that kind of
chlorotic yellow halo pink rot is the
picture in the middle on the bottom and
we would not notice this until we went
to cut open the potato and it is a
problem because your soil was too wet
and particularly as the plants were
maturing and then sometimes we'll see
some skirts the bottom right hand
picture is a picture of black skirt for
Rhizoctonia some of us call it that it's
the dirt that won't wash off and there's
another one that kind of gives our
tubers a bronzy sort of Sheen again
neither of these are anything that you
need to be scared of the the skirts we
can just peel them away they just don't
look pretty they're kind of cosmetic but
the other one we call silver skirt
because of that kind of silvery bronzy
Sheen that we might see on some red
potatoes for physiological disorders the
upper picture is a picture with many
growth cracks the middle picture shows
you secondary growth or what we call
nobs both of these are caused by as well
as hollow heart which is the bottom
left-hand photo all of these are caused
by our potatoes being under some kind of
a stress usually heat stress and/or
water stress then we have an alleviation
of that stress by either cooling of
temperature or by supplying some
irrigation or or getting a rain and then
our potatoes decide that they're gonna
grow really really fast all of a sudden
their fertilizer is available the
temperature is nice so they grow really
fast sometimes they manifest themselves
in a crack on the outside of the potato
sometimes it causes the dormancy
basically to have been broken in some of
those eyes so they form knobs or it
causes a physical tearing on the inside
of the tuber when we have very rapid
growth because the potato can't keep
up and and so we get that hollow heart
or Brown Center we also might see some
different misshapen tubers you might get
the baseball gloves or we might get
these pointy tubers like we have in the
hollow heart picture and then the right
hand picture is bruising this is a
picture of black spot bruising and this
is what happens when we maybe handle our
potato is roughly we're picking them up
into plastic buckets and dumping them
into something else or we are touching
them hard with our potato taking fork so
when we peel it we might see that black
spot then for harvest were we're already
thinking about harvest I have new
potatoes here because a lot of us if we
plant early in the season I know some
people like to plant on Good Friday we
probably it well even if we plant in May
we might have new potatoes for the
fourth of July for example if we want to
harvest a couple of plants
I recommend only harvesting what you can
eat for that meal because they are small
they have very thin skins they desiccate
easily so I would just harvest a plant
or two enough to get a pot of potatoes
to have with peas and and call that good
if we're going to be digging our
potatoes to store then we want to have
more moist soil but not wet but moist
because again that kind of provides a
cushion and then we need to be cognizant
of temperatures growers do not harvest
below soil temperatures of 45 degrees
Fahrenheit and they do not harvest when
the temperature is above 65 degrees
Fahrenheit we have a little bit more
leeway in our home gardens but really
ideally we'd stay in that 20 degree
range of 45 to 65 degrees and then
lastly in terms of storage if we have a
root cellar or something we should be
starting our potatoes at 90 to 95
percent relative humidity we don't want
to have free moisture but we want to
provide humidity because during the
curing part that initial ten days to two
weeks we are allowing our potatoes to
heal up any wounds that they might have
and also to allow for the skins to set
if need be we want to keep the initial
temperature in that 50 to 60 degree
range if we're going to be storing our
potatoes over the winter then we
gradually lower about one degree a day
down to 38 to 40 degrees if we can and
then I have light and light is really
key again because if we forget to leave
the light on in our root cellar or we
have an open window in our basement and
our you know on the uncurtained window
in our basement and that's where we're
storing our potatoes they're going to be
exposed to light and we're going to
develop some greening some people are
actually allergic to that green area and
we can peel it away but if we don't and
someone eats that they can develop a
tummy ache or develop some flu-like
symptoms and this is due to natural
insecticide called glyco alkaloids in
the foliage and so that same thing
happens in our tubers because our tubers
are modified stems okay I think I've
covered a lot of ground I didn't talk
quite as fast maybe as I thought I was
going to but I'm game to answer
questions if people have them
Susie there was one question so far from
Dianne what can we do for scab okay well
um scab is a soil borne fungus so it if
people have it in their soil then if
rotation is an option I would consider
that you know to somewhere else in their
garden maybe where they haven't grown
potatoes or other solanaceous crops
recently there are very few fungicidal
like seed piece or seed treatments or
anything like that that we can use there
are some varieties that are a little
less susceptible than others but this
might be a good instance where the they
maybe want to get a soil test and see
what their soil pH is maybe their this
would be an opportunity to do a little
bit of soil amendment
you know add lime if that if the pH is
too high or add something else if they
are growing potatoes on a more acidic
soil because people also get common scab
on acid acid soils it's called acid scab
in those cases we have time for one more
question and we have one more here
what cultivar do you recommend for a
potato box for a potato box I guess I
don't I'm I'm I'm not sure what they're
referring to as a potato box maybe they
can maybe I can answer the other
question that popped up while they
described what a potato box's sure can
you use your store and potatoes for seed
potatoes I do not recommend that people
use their own potatoes as seed potatoes
because you are not a seed grower and
you know nobody's coming in and
inspecting your crop during the growing
season and inspecting it during the
storage season like like real certified
seed potato growers do i I think that in
many cases your yields are going to
decline you're gonna wind up with a lot
smaller of tubers and you're gonna have
unthrifty plants so here's a little more
on the potato box question she means
growing potatoes in an elevated box
where you add layers to the box as the
potatoes grow okay this is a great
question I have not ever grown potatoes
in in such a growing system but because
they are growing in a box like that I'm
guessing that you're looking for
something that is going to be putting on
additional stolons and growing more
tubers you probably would want to pick a
variety that would be more of an
indeterminant variety than something
like red Norland is very determinate
it's you know and also very early
maturing so so I would not pick
something like that out of our
and I probably would not pick a Yukon
Gold either because they they're not
going to set more tubers this is a
little perplexing a variety that might
work would be Red List soda if you could
find it I think that our Dakota Ruby
could there are some European varieties
that you might find around there's one
called Molly it produces a lot of little
round tubers probably 20 per plant and
they would have yellow flesh but again
it's kind of going to depend what your
what's available at you know for your in
terms of your source you were a garden
supply store or your grocery store or or
maybe you have a favorite seed catalog
so we have two more questions and then
we're going to have to set it up for the
day from Linda can you use your stored
potatoes for seed potatoes okay I answer
that one previously and I indicated that
I prefer that you not I think that
you're going to see a significant yield
decline because if your potatoes have
picked up viruses or other diseases they
the tubers are not going to enlarge very
much also your plants are not going to
look healthy and your your crop is only
as good as the quality of your seed okay
and final question does the purple color
or whatever color disappear after
boiling this is a great question the
purple if you're growing something yes
growing something like all blue or or
say you bought it at the farmers market
or there are some purple ones that have
recently come out of Colorado and I
can't say the name of it but um if you
leave the skins on the purple color will
be retained in the flesh if you peel
them and put them into your salted water
or whatever then yes the potato or that
that purple color is going to dissipate
and if you tried to mash them they would
be great if you want to retain them one
excellent preparation method is baking
or microwaving and a lot of times in
when I didn't grow the purple ones my
girls were little are one of our school
colors was purple we would make purple
french fries and I actually would bake
them on a baking stone effort after I
peeled them and then the purple color
was retained and of course they got a
little golden brown on the edges but but
you could still tell that they were
purple oh it sounds like fun
well I think I'll wrap it up for the day
and I first want to thank Suzy Thompson
for a great talk we I think we all
learned a lot and I also want to thank
all of you for joining us and please
join us again next week